- We're gonna make less
money this year at $100 million
than we made last year at $67.
Net. I don't mean percentage.
Net.
Meaning they're in trouble.
Them.
(group laughter)
I see it which means
I over-invested.
More people,
more capabilities
because I'm gonna take
the whole fucking pie.
You know what I mean?
I'm not worried about how much
cash I'm gonna take home in 2016
because I can take
a lot more in 2020.
It's much more fun to take
home $44 million in 2020
than $3 million in
2017, '18 and '19.
Instead of $4 million.
People are, 99% of the
market is short term.
And the 1% that isn't and
has the talent wins every time.
Which makes no sense because
unless you're gonna die
you should only play long term.
There is a stat that some
dude in Mexico City said
one of these futurist
type characters.
I'm sure he's smart.
I have no idea who so I just
but he was right before me
as I was mic'd up and he says,
"It's been
scientifically proven,"
so I don't know if it has or
not because I've learned to
take that with
a grain of salt but
"that 85% of what
"humans make decisions
about is irrational."
And that spoke to me.
Because A,
I think it's higher and
B, it's why I think all my
success is happening.
I am stunningly the most
rational and the most practical
of all yet I don't seem it.
And when he said it I'm like,
"Right, that's why."
"Because the rest of
the market is irrational."
(hip hop music)